- [interviewer] All right.
Michelle, Michelle, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Michelle] The Valley.
- [interviewer] San Fernando Valley?
- [Michelle] Yes.
- [interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Until I was 11.
- [interviewer] And what happened at 11?
Parents split up?
- My parents split up went
to go live with my uncle
which is my mom's brother
and everything downhill from there.
- [interviewer] And what
kind of stuff happened then?
- Well, I was the baby and my brother
he's the oldest.
And then my sister, the middle
child and being the baby
they're more vulnerable.
So
being young,
I was molested and raped every other night
by my uncle.
My mom was too busy trying
to take care of three kids
school, work,
she was never really home.
My brother he's the oldest.
So he was out partying and stuff.
My sister, she basically
went off with her friends
put her nose in a book and just like
in her own little world.
So being the youngest,
my uncle, I guess
knew it was easy to take advantage of me.
So he told me if I ever
said anything, you know
he'd kick my whole
family out in the street.
They'll abandon me.
He put me up for adoption and everything
if I got my mom and my brother
and my sister kicked out
of the house.
So,
- [interviewer] So to protect the family,
you had to be quiet.
- Yeah I had to keep a secret.
- [interviewer] That's horrible.
- Until I was 17.
And then, you know, met my soulmate.
So to speak,
got pregnant,
moved out of the house
had my little baby girl.
And then I got pregnant again.
I was going to have a boy,
but I got stressed out one day
you know, due to a death in the family.
And I had a miscarriage
at five months
nonetheless. And
- [interviewer] There's
your second child on the way
- It's was going to be a boy.
So what happened there
the miscarriage is my
baby was already so big
they had to cut my baby up
inside me and pull him out.
Unfortunately, when they cut
him out, they accidentally
cut a little bit of my
uterus so I can never
have kids again.
And that broke my heart.
Nonetheless, I lost my baby
and he was so upset about it.
He went and went done something stupid.
He did a drive by with
a couple of his friends
because he was so drunk and so mad.
And he didn't pull the
trigger from my understanding
what he told me.
But he did the one thing.
He hid the gun and while hiding the gun
his fingerprints were on it.
So they raided the house
one day, found the gun
and they took him to jail
for nonetheless murder.
So
- [interviewer] So this was
your boyfriend or husband?
- My soulmate at time.
Yeah. I was going to
marry him, got engaged
had my baby girl, everything
was just going so perfect.
And when he went to jail,
you know, court proceedings
every weekend I did my best
and they sentenced
him twenty-five to life.
So I lost him
in the process.
I started doing drugs again.
I started, I lost almost everything.
My girl, however, I gave
custody to my family.
So
- [interviewer] Your and your
daughter is Christina who
- Right. Exactly.
Yeah. She's a big girl now.
You know, I did the best I could with her
even though she was in their custody.
I took care of her even though
- [interviewer] Yeah.
regardless of a drug habit, whatnot.
And she had, you know
- [interviewer] Christina who
people have seen on my channel.
She's 16 now?
Yeah, she's a big girl.
- [interviewer] And she's where is she?
Who raised her?
- Me and my mom.
She did cause my mom finally moved
out and got her own place.
So gave custody to my mom.
- [interviewer] But then Christina is
on the street now kind of like her mom.
- Yeah, she likes, yeah.
She's wild.
She likes to venture out and
yeah,
she's doing good.
She's off and off, you
know, jobs and everything.
She tries.
So, I mean, I can't be mad at her.
- [interviewer] No, she's a smart girl.
- Very, very.
- [Interviewer] And you
guys have any kind of
relationship now?
- Oh yeah. She comes, she finds me.
She talks to me, you know
we go on little outings
every time when she comes.
- [interviewer] So you have
a good relationship with her?
- Yeah. Very good.
She knows what I do.
I don't keep no secrets from her.
Yeah, yeah.
We get along just fine.
- [interviewer] So
she's your one and only?
- Yeah my only one I can't have no more.
- [interviewer] And your drug is crack?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [interviewer] And you've been using it
steadily ever since?
- Yeah. Ever since that incident.
Yeah.
- [interviewer] Do you, do
you look this, you know, like
like your daughter's living on the street
you're living on the
street, your childhood was
was certainly not perfect.
It's almost like a chain
of destruction that just
keeps going on and on and on.
- Yeah. I think
if I would've been there home
with her, she would never.
- [interviewer] Right. Yeah.
Or if your mom was, or
your parents hadn't split
up and if your mom is
a little more aware of
what was going on.
- Exactly. Then I wouldn't be
in this position, but you know
things happen it's life.
And just
because my emotional
breakdown, you know, everything
went to hell.
- [interviewer] So today
you're, you're working
as a prostitute and on skid row.
- Yeah.
- [interviewer] And that
gets dangerous, right?
That's a horrible lifestyle.
- It does.
- Yes, I almost lost my life like twice.
- [Interviewer] Because some
of the guys that pick you up?
- Yeah.
- [interviewer] I hear that a lot.
- You have to be really careful.
- [interviewer] You
get arrested sometimes?
- Well, I haven't got
arrested in quite a few years
cause I don't
I don't try and be out
there as much as I do, but
- [interviewer] What do you I mean
What do you think would help Christina?
but what do you think would
be the right thing for her?
It's the same.
- I think she should go back to school.
Cause she is very, very
smart and just, you know
her little habits, she needs
to ease up on a little bit
but I don't want to be a hypocrite.
And I mean, I done the same
thing and it'd be wrong
if I'm still doing the same
thing, telling her not to.
You know. Mommy does it
so why can't I, but that's
why I'm going, trying little
by little to change everything.
My housing is just going through and
- [interviewer] So you're
living in a tent currently?
- Yeah.
And as soon as I get stable with that,
she's coming with me.
- [interviewer] Oh really? That's great.
Yeah.
- [interviewer] Maybe, maybe
her getting her life together
might help her mom.
- Yeah, pretty much.
I had to make sacrifices.
- [interviewer] What's
the, what's the worst thing
about having a childhood
that is as unstable
as yours was, is, is
just like, you never feel
you can climb out of it?
- You don't feel anything
it's like a nightmare every day.
And I mean, I'd done some stuff.
Cutting. I burned myself, everything.
And I kept telling
myself, wake up, wake up.
This is a nightmare.
This is not your life.
Wake up.
Almost every other day.
I was so angry.
And I had to keep a secret for so long.
But throughout when she was
growing up, I told my mom
don't let any anybody near her.
And like I said, I did my
best to be around more often
than out here.
And I didn't let anybody get to her.
So she wouldn't be like me and have that.
So a really experience
- [interviewer] Yeah. The
stuff you went through,
it impacts your self worth
and it makes you almost not able to accept
- Right
- [interviewer] a better life
or a better partner, a better
job or a better anything.
Right?
- Right.
- [interviewer] It's like a
curse that just follows you
everywhere you go.
- Yeah.
- [interviewer] And then drugs to come
in the picture and then they
become hard to break and
- [interviewer] Yeah. But I mean, it's bad
and I should try something
else, but it's just that
that's the only thing
that keeps me in my body.
It's like, it keeps me
from not to feel that all
that pain that I have.
- [interviewer] Yeah.
But you were clean when you had Christina.
- Yeah. I was.
- [interviewer] Yeah that's great.
And your life was pretty all
well, I mean, I'm sure
you were still dealing
with some stuff back
then from your childhood.
- Yeah. I mean, it's still,
I'm still dealing with things
from my childhood and I'm
very, very over-protective.
And for the most part, she had a good life
for the most part, except
for being out here.
But I said, as soon as this
goes through, she's out of here.
- [interviewer] Good for you.
She's still young.
- Yeah, she is.
And I want her to have the
ability to have a better life
and to change all this.
- [interviewer] So this, you have a plan
- Yeah and it's already in motion, so
- [interviewer] So where would that be
off of skid row or in skid row?
- Well, the first starting of that plan is
on skid row because you
have to go through SROs
and then, you know, it
becomes section eight
but now the things are
going with the corona thing.
They're more likely to give
you section eight off the top.
So it's, it's moving,
it's going a lot better.
- [interviewer] Good.
- And section eight is
anywhere in the County
so we don't have to be in downtown.
- [interviewer] Oh, that's great.
Getting away from here
and the drugs might do the thing
- Exactly.
- Do something different.
- [interviewer] Yeah. Maybe
you guys can help each other.
- Yeah. I think I need her
just as much as she needs me.
- [interviewer] All right, Michelle,
thank you so much for coming in
and talking with me.
- You're welcome.
- [interviewer] And good
luck with, with everything.
It sounds like a good plan.
- Thank you.
- [interviewer] Thank you.